Speaker 1: Well, I have a bag of mail to review
with you. It's not a literal bag. It's a proverbial
bag, but it's a bag nonetheless. You can email
info at David Pakman dot com if you would
like to get a message through to us. It may
be featured on an upcoming episode. It may
not. I am going to start with this is this
has to be a presented without comment because
it's so wacky. But this is the sort of thing
that I get every day. And one of the things
that I wonder about is what must be going
on in this person's life, to think, to write
such a message to someone they don't know.
Hey, you racist, liberal lunatics. Peter Puffer
Communist, socialist, socialism, culture.
F That's the F word. I hope you boy Biden
f you you. Life and all around you up. Cause
if you retards. Not a word I use is just verbatim.
Cause if you retards believe that woman testimony
in that s show. Hear what somebody told somebody
told somebody. I overheard that you all bunch
of butt buddy do each other off air. So would
you say this is truth? I would not say this
is truth. I would not say that this message
contains truth. The profile image has a NASCAR
vehicle. For this person who wrote in. All
right, folks, let's continue. It's crazy out
there. Duane wrote in and says, I can't believe
you still defend this gene therapy. So, Dave,
you're getting the fifth after the sixth,
I assume they mean vaccines. I don't know.
Duane says, anyway, this is old news, but
I wanted your opinion on a list of things
Trump did. Just a few things to show he actually
took them on. The elite Obama, Hillary, Pelosi,
blah blah. The cutting taxes and regulations
for small business. I couldn't tell exactly
what taxes, but did he cut them? This person
seems very confident in their confusion. Some
people said they benefited more money in their
pockets, never mind the debt. 25 trillion
to China funding the war in Afghan and Iraq.
Okay, never mind that. Did you get more money?
Did you lower taxes? My grammar is not the
best. I have common sense over you high intellects
with degrees. You can't get that from college.
And I use short form like you and couldn't.
Okay. I'm not putting quotation marks like
you freaks. I once met someone who used quotation
marks. They were a freak. That's true. SEC
cut funding from W.H.O.. Not on the agenda.
If people think he's with them, a globalist,
whatever globalist don't agree with some of
things he did. So first is cut taxes. Second
is cut money from W.H.O.. Third, cut funding
from NATO. Not on the agenda. U.S. was paying
the most not part of the EU, not on the AG.
So that's four. So now five now have to scrap
that. Yes, he agreed to another crappy deal,
but not on the AG six Obamacare, which is
a scam. But I had a better one. So we'll say
five for now. EU cut funding. Can't remember
details but was getting out if had one again
that six. There was one more I can't remember.
Can you comment on those six? I can destroy
the SC failed vaccine and the fake pandemic.
COVID is real. The word pandemic is fake.
That's another topic. Don't comment on my
grammar instead of a comma I can double tap
the spacebar. And it's a period. I'm on my
phone. Wow, folks, I can't do it. I think
I might have to quit. These emails are driving
me into retirement. All right. Now for some
more substantive things, Santa wrote in, Hey,
David, assuming Democrats don't find a way
to find a way to codify Roe v Wade into law
any time in the near future, do you think
states were abortion is legal? We'll have
an entire industry of abortion clinics start
to develop along their borders with states
where it's illegal. If so, what other things
do you foresee happening? Yeah, this is interesting
because it reminds me when I grew up in Massachusetts,
it was known fireworks were really I don't
know if they're still illegal in Massachusetts.
Fireworks were illegal in Massachusetts, but
legal in New Hampshire. So there would be
fireworks stores right on the border of New
Hampshire and Massachusetts and people would
drive there. It almost seems certain that
we will see something similar with abortion.
How would we not? How would we not? And the
question that remains is whether states that
ban abortion will try to prosecute those who
leave the state and legally get an abortion
elsewhere. I don't think there's really a
legal basis for that. I've spoken to lawyers
and they've not they've not articulated to
me. How do you how would you do that? If you
go to a state where an abortion is legal.
It's sort of like if you go to I don't know
if you go to Amsterdam and consume cannabis
where it's legal and then come back to the
U.S. to a state where it's illegal, could
the state prosecute you for what you did in
Amsterdam? It doesn't seem like it. So that's
a question. But I think you will indeed see
such a such an industry develop, and it's
a horrible thing to think about. Mark wrote
in about hearsay and asked, Hi, David, is
Casity Hutchinson's testimony hearsay? Please
share your thoughts. If you have a minute,
it seems part of it could be in part of it
not. Thanks for all you do and congratulations
on your baby. So there's two answers to this
question. Is so hearsay is a legal term relevant
in courts of law? So the first question is,
why are we even talking about hearsay in a
congressional hearing? Hearsay is allowed
in congressional hearings. So that's not an
issue. Second part, there are people who,
when they say is it hearsay, you can tell
believe that if it's hearsay, it can't be
believed. Sometimes hearsay is true. And so
whether or not it's hearsay is a different
question from whether or not Cassidy Hutchinson's
testimony was accurate. And then third, even
in courts of law, there are dozens of hearsay
exemptions or exceptions wherein hearsay is
allowed. So, yes. CASSIDY Because some of
Cassidy Hutchinson's testimony, if presented
in a court of law, would be hearsay that has
no bearing on its truth and it has no bearing
on whether it is acceptable in a congressional
hearing. Matt Roden. Comment on Tucker's June
28 show. Hi, sir. I heard your show on John
Eastman on Tucker's show. Tucker said they're
treating Eastman like a drug kingpin or a
rapist. Shouldn't he have said a drunk drug
kingpin or a woman who just had an illegal
abortion? I believe the punishment is far
worse that than the actual rapist. Just a
thought. Yeah. So I think the point being
made here by Matt is there are many who want
to criminalize abortion. Usually they stop
short of saying criminalize the woman's action.
They will often say criminalize the doctor,
etc.. But point well taken. They are sort
of relegating women seeking medical services
to criminals. And that's crazy. A few other
aggressive ones. Whose payroll are you? On
a whole, no matter what they're paying you.
You're going against your country. You piece
of s f you. I'm not on anyone's payroll other
than yours. It's the people in the audience
who support the work that we do. So. I guess
I'm on my own payroll in that I own my own
business and I'm on the payroll of the audience
because the audience funds the show. Beyond
that, you know, whenever people talk about
Soros or whoever else is paying me. Prove
it. Prove someone other than the audience
and our few advertisers are paying me. Please.
Do you guys get triggered much? Because it
seems like you do. Do you care? On all the
riots the Democrats did for the last six years.
I'll wait for your response. Well, I have
unequivocally denounced violence, and it has
been something I've said, regardless of who's
doing it or the political orientation of those
doing it. We know that in the United States,
the overwhelming majority of politically motivated
violence is perpetrated by the right, not
by the left. Democrats did riots for six years.
You're going to have to remind me about that.
When there has been violence or criminality
at whatever protest, Black Lives Matter, entre,
for anything I say, I'm against that. And
if crimes have been committed, then people
should be dealt with in the criminal justice
system. And we saw nothing from them like
what we saw on January six. So I hope that
you weren't waiting too long, and I hope that
I answered your question. Last one. You have
a chance to see 2000 mules, but I think your
y.o., you are afraid to watch and read the
laptop from hell. Your president and his nasty
son. All over it. I have now talked about
2000 mules three times. I think that is more
than sufficient for how rigorous it is. Three
times I've spoken about 2000 mules. I have
spoken about the Hunter Biden laptop, now
probably closer to six or seven times. I've
basically said everything I think should be
said about it. Based on what we know so far.
If you think there's something specific that
should be said that I haven't said, let me
know. Maybe even call into the show. We have
a fantastic bonus show for you today. Sign
up at join pacman dot com. That's PAC man
dot.com to get instant access to the bonus
show. You also get the daily podcast in either
audio or video form, whichever form you prefer.
When you were a member, that podcast full
show is made available to you five or 6 hours
earlier than we publish it to everybody else.
And when we do our town hall events, you get
priority access when you are a member. Join
pacman dot com coupon code big voting 22.
We will see you on the bonus show and then
we will see you next week.